olivia wilde served with custody papers
from her ex jason siddiques while making
a presentation at cinemacon an
eyewitness attending the event in vegas
tells e.t that she was introducing the
never-before-seen trailer for her new
movie don't worry darling when an
unidentified person approached the stage
and slid a manila envelope towards her
and when presented with the envelope
which was marked personal and
confidential she asked if it was for her
the eyewitness says the scene was odd
but everyone assumed it was something
about her presentation and olivia she
didn't seem to be shaken by what had
just transpired in fact she laughed off
the moment so much so that people
attending the event wondered if it was
some sort of bit but that envelope was
never addressed again it's too bizarre
so what was in there jason's rep tells
e.t papers were drawn up to establish
jurisdiction relating to the children
the former couple share two kids otis
and daisy
jason's rep insists the actor had no
prior knowledge of the time or place
that the envelope would have been
delivered as this would solely be up to
the process service company involved and
he would never condone her being served
in such an inappropriate manner and
turns out the head of cinemacon mitch
newhauser had no idea this was going to
happen either in a statement to e.t he
says quote a situation like this has
never happened before and the priority
at this convention has always been to
protect the integrity of our studio
partners and talent in attendance adding
that they're taking this incident very
seriously and will be re-evaluating
security protocols
jason and olivia have a long history
together the pair began dating in 2011
and he popped the question a year later
but by 2020 they ended their engagement
and get this just days before jason and
olivia announced their split the actor
gushed to et about how proud he was of
her directing her project don't worry
darling oh she loves it and she's great
in it and it's amazing the
to see her resilience and and and she
just you know she just works her butt
off she's editing the stuff they already
shot you know she's using her time you
know and she has so many other projects
in the in the works that she you know
she's
she's uh
kicks ass that way
[Music]
you